You ever feel frustrated when a show wraps
up before the long summer hiatus and leaves
things unresolved?
Hey, it's just a season finale.
You'll get closure when that show returns
in the fall.
But then there are some long-running TV shows
that ended a season on their cliffhanger—and
then got canceled.
Here are some shows where audiences never
got to find out what happened.
Mork and Mindy
Elevated by the staggering comic gifts of
Robin Williams, this show's four-season run
came to an end in a truly weird fashion.
An evil alien named Kelnik tries to kill Mork
and Mindy, but they escape using a pair of
magical time-travelling shoes.
But oops!
They're damaged, and the pair go too far back
in time.
The last image: a cave painting of Mork and
Mindy.
Did they ever get back to the future?
We'll never know, because the show got canceled.
Sliders
On the final installment of Sliders, a show
featuring a cast of dimension-hopping characters,
a psychic tells the crew that if they slide
through space and time just once more, they'll
die.
However, they find a loophole: if one of them
slides but also injects themselves with a
special tonic, they'll be okay.
The character Rembrandt does it and slides
on through.
Does he live?
Does he die?
The psychic could tell the others, but while
fighting off the team's enemies, she dies.
Freaks and Geeks
Freaks and Geeks made stars out of cast members
like James Franco and Seth Rogen.
But when this show aired in 1999, it finished
near the bottom of the ratings.
NBC canceled it before all 18 episodes were
broadcast.
One of the season's story arcs followed Lindsay
Weir and her struggles with whether or not
to remain a hard-working, school-first good
girl.
She ultimately ditches an academic summit
to go to a Grateful Dead concert.
At the end, Lindsay hops in a van, and it
drives away…and we never know if Lindsay
made it there, or back.
My Name is Earl
This sitcom followed around an amiable dirtbag
named Earl, played by Jason Lee, who wins
the lottery and spends his life making amends
for all the bad things he's done.
Despite being a big hit for NBC, it was abruptly
canceled at the end of season four in 2009.
The last scene drops a bombshell: Earl's actually
the father of his ex-wife's baby, and she's
about to explain!
But the episode—and series—ends with a
"To Be Continued" graphic.
"NBC?"
"That's for canceling My Name is Earl!"
Lois and Clark: The New Adventures of Superman
Each decade gets the Superman it deserves.
Sad, post-Watergate '70s America got happy-positive
Christopher Reeve, and superficial, Melrose
Place-loving '90s America got this soapy super-show
starring Dean Cain and Teri Hatcher.
Season four ended with a super-seeming baby
left on Lois and Clark's doorstep.
Was it from Krypton like Superman?
Who knows?
ABC decided a fifth season wasn’t such a
super idea.
Angel
Toward the end of its run, Angel and his gang
take on the evil law firm of Wolfram and Hart.
The final scene of season five shows the protagonists
preparing to storm their enemies.
The show's creative team didn't intend for
this to be the ending, but they learned too
late that they weren't getting renewed, so
they ended the show on a cliffhanger.
But creator Joss Whedon is okay with that,
satisfied it suggests the fight against evil
never truly ends.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
cliffhanger frustrated you most.